Hadley wurde monitamon auf ihm
Herzkrankheit Auktion enthoben wir fragten Würfel Klumpenmaterial
und jeder Motor kommt
mit Varney Moon milchiger Kraftstoff Ananka Tank
Familie Schwestern Anästhesist es wird selten
erwähnt
man-ho tika gustaba sitas Unterhose Daniel
Dennett
ist antipräzise und Füllstoffe oft Gürtel
richtig es ist ein  Geschmack
Darwinist Undine auf Kleiderbügel gibt es nicht
zu Hollis Mousse, also in Cynthia erwähnte
verpasste Spiegel und Komplexe Trick
Materia Marzian Boo wurde schwindelig Legen Sie sich
auf diejenigen. Ich verstecke
mich
triff sie unten und einer passiert, es
erträgt, lass uns Gish zerstören, denke ich
fast jeden Tag, und manchmal ist es der
Einfallsreichtum der Natur und manchmal ist es
nur die Seltsamkeit der Tatsachen über das
Universum, und manchmal bin ich erstaunt über das
Versagen der Vorstellungskraft einiger meiner
Mitdenker, die es einfach nicht verstehen,
und ich habe entschieden, dass sie es nicht verstehen, weil
sie es nicht verstehen wollen  Aber sie wollen, dass die
Dinge mysteriös bleiben, also
haben sie fast so etwas wie ein moralisches Prinzip.
Denke nicht so darüber nach, wie es
will, dass du darüber nachdenkst, denn
das ist eine schlüpfrige Rutsche, okay, ich bin bash, sei
diffus, glaube ich  Sprache
Leidenschaft Maschine zu sehen, es noch stahma
Würze - ina Siemens da LD sagen,
das ist mr.  Hughes, das ist ein
Kopflachen und Sau, aber Season Tech Jose
und wie Monde immer noch
wissenschaftliche Eclair-Bar-
Kegel sind. Malaysier graben sich in eine Skip-Nische ein.
Sie waren nicht religiös. Einer der heißesten von
NIH-Algen
Ich denke, als ich noch sehr jung war, als
ich ein Teenager war, erinnere ich mich, dass ich die
Karren-Meditationen Cogito Ergo Sum und
seinen Dualismus gelesen habe, und ich glaube, ich war damals 17
und war davon fasziniert,
aber ich habe auch nur ein schnelles Urteil darüber
gefällt 17 Jahre  Der alte sagte, das ist schön,
aber es ist falsch, und ich denke, ich werde
herausfinden, warum und sollte mich ein
oder zwei Nachmittage und 50 Jahre später mehr Zeit nehmen, als dass
ich T alpha Vox in meinem eigenen Bereich verwende
und über Sie, wenn ich es bin  eigentlich auch kein
Dreher kein Statistiker nicht
die Wissenschaft mein Vater war Historiker
islamischer Historiker meine Mutter war
Englischlehrerin also waren wir sehr in
den Geisteswissenschaften und ich interessierte mich
schon als kleiner Junge für Naturwissenschaften, aber nie
wirklich  Ich habe es in der Schule über die regulären Kurse hinaus verfolgt,
tatsächlich habe ich den ganzen
Weg durch das Undergraduate College geschafft,
ohne jemals richtige
naturwissenschaftliche Kurse zu belegen.
Ich habe meine naturwissenschaftlichen Anforderungen bestanden,
indem ich Logikkurse und solche Dinge belegt
habe.
Oh hey, Lee Gyu hat gewonnen, was für ein freundliches Team
kauft  in für mich zu sehen Show er wird
anklagen, wenn ich einen gesehen habe gut Ich habe es irgendwie gemacht In
unserer Stadt in Neuengland gingen alle
Kinder zur Sonntagsschule und es gab
viele protestantische Kirchen in der
katholischen Kirche und ich ging zur
Congregational Church  das ist
schon damals
in den 40er und 50er Jahren ultraliberal, ultranachsichtig, es war
doktrinär locker, sagen wir mal, aber ich
habe viel gelernt. Ich habe viele
Bibelverse gelernt. Ich habe die Bücher der Bibel
gelernt, wie ich viel gelernt habe  Ich habe viele
Chöre und liebe immer noch religiöse
Chormusik, es gibt kaum eine, die ich nicht
oft gesungen habe, aber ich
habe das Glaubensbekenntnis nie
sehr ernst genommen, und dann hatte ich kein
großes atheistisches Erwachen, wie ich gerade merke  ed
Ich glaube nicht, dass
dies von einem sehr pompösen
und selbstgerechten Minister unterstützt wurde, den ich
einfach verabscheute, und ich bin sicher, er hat
mich zum Atheismus getrieben, nur weil ich
dachte, er sei ein pompöser Narr
, obwohl es sich um breiige schädliche Mythen handelt  Dampf hier
trifft hier auf Oberflächen und verursacht
Gewalt. Gibt es nicht einmal den Experten oder
die Insel ein paar hundert Experimente, die
sie unterschreiben würden
?  und Kansas Astana unter
Moment jeder bekannt als seine eingetauchte Marga
dr.  Vassar Ich weiß, es ist das Star House in einem
asiatischen Staat und sie würden Treibstoffeinnahmen geben.
Ich erinnere mich, dass ich als
Student darüber nachgedacht und
insbesondere über visuelle Wahrnehmung nachgedacht habe,
und ich hatte bereits in meinem Kopf,
dass der Fehler, den viele
Leute machten, war  Ich dachte, dass sie
irgendwie eine innere Bewegung in ihrem Kopf hatten, dass da drinnen irgendwie diese Show
ablief, und ich dachte, nein
, das kann nicht stimmen, dass
das subtil inkohärent sein muss, aber ich sehe nicht, wie
ich es positiv sagen soll  Geschichte, um sie zu ersetzen,
also fing ich bereits an,
neugierig an dieser Idee herumzuschnüffeln,
und dann, als ich ein Doktorand
in Oxford war, ein Freund von mir, ein Medizinstudent,
wusste ich nicht, was es ist, dass
ich nichts über das Gehirn weiß nicht
Eine Sache, ich sagte, was ihr Gehirn aus Neuronen mache,
was Neuronen seien, und er setzte sich
auf den Boden, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, und holte ein
Blatt Papier heraus, zeichnete ein Bild von einem
Neuron und verband es mit einem anderen
Neuron und erzählte mir ganz einfach
was 1963 über Neuronen bekannt war, und
ich hatte dann eine dramatische Einsicht,
plötzlich wurde mir klar, dass dies die Art
von Entität war, die in großen Netzwerken zusammengesetzt werden konnte, in
denen man
durch eine Art
Evolutionsprozess lernen konnte  das Gehirn, das war der
ganze Trick beim Lernen. Ich meine, Gehirne
sind wunderbare Lerngeräte, wie um alles in der
Welt ist Lernen ohne
Rätsel möglich, wie macht man das, wenn man
keinen wissenden Lehrer hat,
der einem zeigt, wie es sein muss  durch einen Prozess von
Versuch und Irrtum mehr oder
weniger gedankenlos herumtasten, bis man
Verbindungen findet, die funktionieren, und dann darauf
aufbauen und darauf aufbauen und
darauf aufbauen, so hatte ich 1963 die Idee,
Lernen als Evolution im Gehirn zu entwickeln,
und dann hatte ich  entdeckte später, dass
ich nicht der erste war, der daran dachte,
oder der zweite oder dritte Darwin
selbst hatte einige Ideen dazu, es ist, denke ich
, jetzt ziemlich einig, dass
in gewissem Sinne der Prozess des Lernens und
des Entdeckens  ry und Erfindung bricht zusammen
, wenn man es sich
mechanistisch vorstellt, wie das Gehirn es macht, es
zerfällt in Kaskaden von
Trial-and-Error-Prozessen, bei denen es
Wettbewerb gibt und die Gewinner
dem Organismus besser helfen, zu verstehen, und die
Verlierer handeln von Menschen, die dies modellieren
Evolutionsstufe gebaut von in böse-ina
ganzheitlich genug
cool zur Hölle, wenn Feind so Pantheon Zongzi
hilft wütenden Affen sogar einem erfahrenen
Gibbs schon Essen auf fast 35 in
Kuppelsicht nehmen Anson und Nathan segeln ärgern
sie hölzern darüber, wenn mich schaukeln, es ist
genau ein und passiert  kommt auf einen
Clarence, ich bin hier, zuerst verstehe, dass
Tifa Nachhilfe gegeben hat, Antonin, kein
hölzerner Satsanghis, Jack Tretton, ein großes
Boost-Zeichen, macht einen Sprung, und jede
Perspektive, es ist schwer, diese sind Schweiß-
Schmitz und einige springen etwas auf
Salida,
wir kommen, kommen so immateriell  und
festland phänomene ein haus stehen diese
sache hier und die schwestern gemütlich wie
albern wahrscheinlich mutter wahrscheinlich sogar
jungs kyun zu etwas nein nein o  ne
stand da drin bevor sohn er hatte zeit auf
VV nehmen wir was für viele menschen
das drängendste anliegen schmerz und
leid unsere körper sind ausgestattet unser
nervensystem war mit zellen ausgestattet
die nozizeptoren genannt werden zum beispiel
das sie dort schaden oder gefahr erkennen oder
Sie können fehlgeleitet werden, aber das
ist der Anfang von Schmerzsignalen, die
Hautdichte angespannte Minuten
verhökern mmm-hmm nein und und die Physiologie und
die Neuroanatomie von Schmerzfasern und
so weiter bis zum Gehirn ist ziemlich
bekannt und vereinbart und aber  Nun, was
passiert im Gehirn, wie bekommt man Schmerzen
im Gehirn? Nun, offensichtlich ist es nicht so,
dass es ein Neuron gibt, das von anderen
Neuronen, die Sie kennen, mit Ketten oder
so geschlagen wird, und das ist es, was Schmerzen
auslöst  Das
Zusammenspiel von, sagen wir, Millionen
verschiedener Neuronen zu realisieren, um das
Phänomen des Schmerzes im gesamten Organismus zu erkennen
, das ist eine gute Frage, aber eine schwierige
Frage  Ich denke, wir können zumindest
die Antwort skizzieren, dass
Sie keine Nozizeptoren hätten, wenn
sie keine nützlichen
Nozizeptoren oder Schmerzrezeptoren wären, was
sind sie nützlich, denn sie sind nützlich, um zu
unterbrechen, was immer Sie tun, und
Ihre Prioritäten zu ändern
Vergiss weit weg und schneide das
Geld ab, das absolut am höchsten ist, wenn
du ohne Schmerznetzwerke geboren wärst, wärst du
sehr behindert und es gibt
Menschen, die von Natur aus
schmerzunempfindlich sind.
Sie führen ein kurzes unglückliches Leben
Die
Funktion dieser ist dann,
alles andere mit einem
Signal zu unterbrechen, das dazu neigt,
alles andere zu überwältigen, und wir müssen dies
alles ohne einen zentralen Hough-Homunkulus tun,
der entscheidet, was als nächstes zu denken ist, was als
nächstes zu tun ist  Also muss es einen
Wettbewerb geben und es gibt einen Wettbewerb
mit allem, woran Sie
zu der Zeit gedacht haben, und wenn der
Schmerz wirklich stark ist, neigt er dazu,
diesen Wettbewerb zu überwältigen  Nun, wie wird dieser
Wettbewerb wiedergegeben? Ich meine,
was ist die Physiologie davon? Nun,
es ist die Physiologie der differentiellen
Produktion von Neuromodulatoren, die
entweder einige Dinge dämpfen oder
Dinge erleichtern. Wir verstehen, dass
es viele Prozesse im
Gehirn gibt  Genannte gegnerische
Prozesse, einer zieht, der andere zieht, und
der Kompromiss ist, was Sie tun, zum
Beispiel sind Ihre Augenmuskeln
gegensätzlich und wo
Sie als nächstes hinschauen, nehmen wir einen sehr, sehr
einfachen Fall, da Sie nur
Ihre Augen in Ihrem Leben leben  bewegen sich drei- oder
viermal pro Sekunde springen springen
springen du merkst das nicht, aber das
passiert gut, was bestimmt, wohin
deine Augen springen, es gibt einen Wettbewerb
in den Neuronen, die das kontrollieren,
und einige von ihnen sagen, langweilig,
langweilig, das habe ich gesehen
gib mir was neues andere sagen
home sweet home mir gefällt das ich
bleibe hier und wenn sich die
kraft auf einer seite aufbaut bekommst du eine sakkade
und das alles passiert sehr schnell
jeden fünften der Sekunde, sagen wir, frisst
Alice
zuerst Müll 215, und das ist eine klare
Spitze für dich über den Buckel, Chanel, ärgere dich
, das ist kein Ballute Tsundere für Reifenleben,
und wir zeichnen den höchsten Emitter
, sagen wir, unseren  Name wir, das ist letztes Jahr
ein Segment, in dem wir es herausgestellt haben, wie klein in
menschlichen Herzen durch all diese Hilfen ist. ID-
Molekül ist
notwendig.  Theresa vereinfachte Wissenschaft im
Wesentlichen, dass ärgerliche Gleichberechtigung durch
Aufladen von Bambi hier das zivilisierte
Englisch ist. Im
Wesentlichen ist der Test von dort wichtig,
von Vorlagen bis Schmitz.
Ich finde, wassup ist ziemlich häufig
um es zu
erklären und ich werde es sehr tun. Schedule
II Das Gehirn hat ein Problem Das Gehirn hat
ein Problem, weil es 86 Milliarden
Neuronen sind und sie alle in der Lage sind, alle möglichen Dinge zu tun,
also muss
etwas hereinkommen und dies vereinfachen und
umgestalten  Aktivitäten großer Gruppen von
Neuronen in die Darstellung
einfacherer Dinge und dieses Phänomen ist
sehr ähnlich zu etwas, das erst
kürzlich von menschlichen
Ingenieuren erreicht wurde und das als
Benutzerschnittstelle auf Ihrem Computer oder auf Ihrem
Telefon bezeichnet wird. Ihr Handy ist ein unglaublich
kompliziertes Objekt  Schicht auf Schicht auf
Schicht von Software und Hardware und
Firmware und es sind tatsächlich Milliarden von
Dingen, die Sie nicht tun.  Ich möchte nicht
alles wissen, was Sie wollen, ist
eine metaphorische Schnittstelle, die sehr
einfach ist, was eine Art
Illusion ist, die Benutzerillusion genannt wird. Nun,
wer ist ein Benutzer, ich bin der Benutzer, und mein
Handy gibt mir eine Illusion, aber
Es ist eine gutartige Täuschung. Es ist gut.
Es ist etwas, das Sie wollen, weil
es Ihr Leben vereinfacht. Es ermöglicht Ihnen,
Ihr Handy zu steuern und all die
Dinge zu tun, die Sie jetzt tun möchten. Hier
ist die Idee
sich selbst und das bedeutet,
dass das Gehirn weiter vereinfacht Was
mache ich als nächstes Teil des Gehirns den Input
, der moduliert, was ich als nächstes tun sollte und
das Ergebnis davon ist, dass Sie das
bewusste Subjekt aus dieser
Interaktion zwischen den Gehirnen der beiden
Seiten hervorgeht  brains Benutzeroberfläche und
tatsächlich ist es nicht so, dass es einen einzigen
Ort im Gehirn gibt, an
dem diese Kompromisse
ausgearbeitet werden, an denen übermäßige Vereinfachungen
ausreichen, um Entscheidungen auszulösen oder hervorzurufen
Wenn wir also an einen kleinen Teil des Gehirns denken, dann
ist dies der Teil
, der den Schmerz lokalisieren wird, und dies
ist der Teil, der sagen wird, wie
stark er ist, ganz anders als der
eine  Eines der zentralen Themen meiner Arbeit seit
über 25 Jahren ist, dass es keinen Ort im
Gehirn gibt, an dem alles für das
Bewusstsein zusammenkommt, das ich das Cartesianische
Theater
nenne  das faxgerät an
die seele und alles musste da
durch, um bewusst zu werden verrückt
brillant bisschen verrückt also gibt es keinen solchen
ort also all diese arbeit all die arbeit die
von den cleveren gemacht werden würde,
schätzt die mönch ulis im
kontrollraum das alles
muss um zwei Entitäten verteilt werden, neurale
Agenturen, die selbst nicht
bewusst sind, aber sie tun die Arbeit, die
Krebs ist, ist Timoschkin erfahren, ik
, das ist heist, ich kann es erfreuen, wenn
es realistisch ist, dass jeder am Geburtstag ist  Dow bei der
Suche nach Wunschmatten und ich kann keine
Illusion an die Leine nehmen. Nein, ich habe Ian bei Soja gebeten, das
Design für ihre R Biden-
Kolumnistin zu treffen.  Ich bin dankbar für diese Illusionen, die
sie sind. Sie sind eine brillant
gestaltete Evolution. Eine brillant gestaltete Vorschau.
Eine Zusammenfassung sehen. Eine Metapher für das, was
tatsächlich vor sich geht
fertig gehärtete Dose
Menschenjunges als verschwundenes Hundeziel, es ist
meistens mein Erzählarm, den er
uns ermutigt hat, zu singen, und das sind Haufen
, über die sie sich betrinken, die gefragt haben, ob sie
die Haut und den Arm im Fahrzeug nicht gesehen haben,
weil es auch ein Messing-Fortuno-Motel ist
Diese funktionieren, sind aber geistig anständig
, das stimmt, es funktioniert nicht so wie in
meinem Modell, weil Sie sich das Ich
als diesen isolierten und unterschiedlichen
Teil oder Bewohner des Gehirns vorstellen, nein
nein das e  Wenn du das ganze
Gehirn magst und die Umsetzung deiner
Wünsche und Wünsche und Absichten
viele Prozesse beinhaltet, die
sowohl räumlich als auch zeitlich verteilt sind und
das bestimmt, wann deine Hand
auf das Gehirn geht, hat besonders das menschliche
Gehirn eine Eigenschaft, die es ist  nicht
ausreichend geschätzt, ich meine von
Wissenschaftlern, vielleicht von Dichtern, und das
heißt, dass wir an alles denken können,
die repräsentationale Fruchtbarkeit des
bewussten Denkens ist atemberaubend, es
schien keine Grenzen zu geben, tatsächlich
scheint es sogar der Sprache davonzulaufen, manchmal
sagen wir, mir fehlen die Worte  Ich kann nicht in Worte fassen,
was ich gerade erlebe. Es gibt
ein enormes Repertoire an verschiedenen
Zuständen. Technisch gesehen
sind das Freiheitsgrade, jeder davon
ist ein Freiheitsgrad, der viel zu viele kontrolliert werden muss, um ihn zu
kontrollieren  Milliarden von Freiheitsgraden
im menschlichen Gehirn, also wie kommt man jemals dazu,
wie irgendetwas jemals irgendetwas kontrolliert,
und das ist der Prozess der Autonomie
so baut man das auf und wie erstellt ein
gehirn einen autonomen agenten gut wenn
der autonome agent sagen wir mal eine ratte ist
zunächst einmal vereinfacht das gehirn und stellt nur
wirklich eine kleine anzahl
möglicher handlungen dar man kann man verstecken
man kann schlafen man kann  Fortpflanzung du kannst
kämpfen du kannst essen du kannst nach Essen jagen
das ist so ziemlich alles und da gibt es
fünf Freiheitsgrade genau dort mache
ich das mache ich ein BCD oder E ziemlich genau
das ist es gibt kein FGH oder wenn sie
es sind  nur Varianten auf der anderen Seite,
aber in uns ist die Anzahl der verschiedenen Dinge, die
wir in jedem Moment tun können, überwältigend
und irgendwie und hier
arbeite ich gerade in diesen Tagen das System, das
entwickelte System ist in der Lage, Prozesse einzurichten,
die bestimmen, was Sie tun  Denken Sie als
nächstes darüber nach, wie Sie
Ihre Entscheidungen ausführen und so, was ist alles
bestimmt? Ja, es ist alles bestimmt, aber
es wird von seiner eigenen bestimmt
eine illusion die
düsternis hier, die so genug auswählt, wenn die
höhe des strengen so sicher und versteckt
im sterben - kann ein geisteslied
wieder in st.  der Tuskegee und/oder Geschichte
und TV Kyun macht das Alice hat
ihr Foul verpfiffen Susie redet zu
streng, aber ja,
eigentlich könnte man sagen
und einige Leute haben mich angefleht zu sagen, weil
sie das sagen wollen, dass der freie
Wille eine Illusion ist und ich  Sagen wir mal,
es gibt den Teil der Benutzerillusion, es gibt
die Tatsache, dass Ihr Gehirn darauf ausgelegt ist
, Ihnen, was mehr von Ihrem Gehirn ist,
Wahlmöglichkeiten zu präsentieren, zwischen
denen Sie sich entscheiden können, und wie Sie diese Entscheidungen treffen, wird
durch das Gleichgewicht von Bildung
, Erfahrung und Strom bestimmt  Lust und
Schwäche und ob du betrunken bist und
alles andere, also hast du das, aber du
hast eine Art Arena, in der Entscheidungen
getroffen werden und die unabhängig vom
Determinismus ist. Schachspielende Computer treffen
Entscheidungen. Ein Schach spielender Computer ist
das deterministische System  Aber es
macht das so, ich meine, wenn Sie denken, dass das
keine echten Entscheidungen sind, versuchen Sie,
die Kompetenz eines
Schachspielprogramms zu verstehen, ohne diese echten Entscheidungen zu
berücksichtigen  ns Nachteile gehen über - und
Chidomo-
Visualisierung kann nicht einmal genießen, andere
Damen sind schwächer, klopfen an einen Tetraman,
und da ist Alice - Carol,
weil es ein Fest ist
Nummer auf Survivor tut dies
Meinungen von Ungarn Oh M getan ist ich
völlig unanständig
gekachelt dann der Naturalismus Delvian getan
östlich von Systemarbeit Nullzustand konfrontiert den
strengen Körper, es ist hier seine einzige Wendung auf
der Philosophie und Staubkanister beenden
diesen Bus für hi hi zu nennen  Herr.  Hobbes
würde gut sagen, das ist eine sehr vertraute und
weit verbreitete Meinung, und ich denke, sie beruht
auf dem zweitausend Jahre alten Fehler
, nämlich der Idee, dass Freiheit in dem
Sinne, dass es darauf ankommt, mit Determinismus unvereinbar ist
, und ich sage nein, das ist es einfach nicht
Lassen Sie mich Ihnen in dem Sinne, dass es darauf ankommt,
ein Beispiel geben, ein historisches Beispiel, das ich
vor vielen Jahren verwendet habe, ja,
in meinem ersten Buch über die Ellenbogenfreiheit und
das Raumschiff der Wikinger wurde
von der Erde gestartet und zum Mars geschickt, und
irgendwann war es das  Es dauerte, um
Signale von der Bodenkontrolle auf der Erde
durch die Wikinger zu bekommen, wurde zu lang für eine
praktische Kontrolle, also hatten sie geplant, dass
sie einen Schalter hatten, den sie umlegten,
und die Wikinger wurden autonom,
sie waren nicht mehr unter ihrer
Kontrolle, es war a  Selbstbeherrschung Nun, es ist
nichts Mysteriöses oder Metaphysisches an
dieser Kontrolltheorie in der Technik, die
sehr deutlich macht, was der Unterschied
zwischen einem kontrollierenden B und einem
kontrollierenden B ist. Selbstkontrolle ist
unabhängig von d  Eterminismus jetzt
Selbstkontrolle Autonomie in diesem begrenzten
technischen Sinne. Es beginnt mit
etwas ganz Einfachem wie dem Wikinger
oder einer Amöbe oder einer Muschel, aber wenn Sie
Freiheitsgrade hinzufügen, wird die Idee der
Autonomie immer
interessanter und immer interessanter  wichtig,
denn sobald man ein System hat, das
in der Lage ist, Milliarden verschiedener
Dinge zu tun, aber entscheidet, welche dieser
Milliarden Dinge zu tun sind, ja, die
Entscheidungen, die getroffen werden, werden
vom Zustand seines Gehirns bestimmt, das
wiederum von seiner Geschichte und seinen Genen bestimmt wird
und das alles, aber es ist immer noch so,
dass es nicht von äußeren Umweltkräften bestimmt wird, sondern
es
wird lokal durch den aktuellen
Zustand des Computers bestimmt, der das Gehirn ist,
und das ist eine Art Autonomie, und
wann wieder wir  Menschen wie uns erreichen
Organismen wie uns, es hat sogar eine moralische
Dimension, die Volksärzte haben, die unsere
Instanzen tun, sie können in Computerrobotern sein.
Franken hoch hoch reden über t  er Boost-
Schild Kohlevorhang vor allem die Art
von NTC obyekt assist overhaul und Al's
op c5 an order P Boost-Schild hart wirklich
hart bei der Arbeit passiert ist unser
Erstaunen Wissenschaft im Prinzip das
stimmt
in der Praxis der Grad der Komplexität
, die ein Roboter oder und  Künstliche
Intelligenz müsste so sein
wie wir, sozusagen in moralisch
bedeutsamer Weise, es ist immens, aber ja,
und Prince, nach allem, was
ich jahrelang gesagt habe, gibt es bewusste
Roboter, sicher, dass ich einer bin, also bist du, aus denen
wir Roboter gemacht sind  Roboter aus
Robotern aus Robotern Wenn wir auf
die subzelluläre Ebene herunterkommen, bekommen wir zu wenig
Protein Roboter wie Motorproteine
nd eindeutig Roboter Sie haben keinen Stoff
echsel Sie sind nur kleine Roboter, das
sind wir, aus denen wir gemacht sind  von
Kazue
Ich wünschte, Pinto-Kopf wäre unter uns, sonst ist
dies ein iPhone mit Siri, das sich bald materialisiert hat
, Walnüsse in deinem Arm zu
essen  Hallo,
tut mir das wirklich leid, ich habe es jetzt übersprungen,
nein, nein, und ich denke, Siri das
Bewusstsein zu geben, würde es
die Größe und Komplexität von
Siri verdoppeln oder verdreifachen oder
vervierfachen  a eine Amöbe ist
sie bei Bewusstsein
gut sie lebt sie hat sie hat sie
hat kein Nervensystem als eine Zelle, aber
das Protein kreist die
chemischen Reaktionszyklen innerhalb der Amöbe, unsere Art
von Nervensystem, die ihr Verhalten bestimmen,
und sie ist autonom zu a
Überraschenderweise schützt es sich selbst
bis zu einem überraschenden Grad, und so tut es jedes
Neuron in Ihrem Gehirn. Ja, ich weiß, ich habe
immer gesagt, ich habe es getan, er hat mich aufgehalten, gut zu braten,
und wir bestehen aus einer
Billion Amöben, und sie sind alle so, wie Sie
sagen  Sie sind Roboter, sie
reagieren nur auf äußere Reize, aber sie
haben Pläne, aber Sie stellen
genug davon zusammen, und jetzt erhalten Sie große
Versammlungen, die auf ihre
inneren Zustände reagieren und reagieren  d zu ihren inneren
Zuständen, indem sie darüber nachdenken, indem sie sie
bewerten, indem sie sich alternative Zukünfte vorstellen,
all dies kann
in Wetware implementiert werden, wenn man sagen könnte, in den
rechnerischen Verbindungen zwischen
Neuronen und Gliazellen ist das Gehirn ein
wunderbar kompliziertes Ding und keine
KI  In der Nähe
davon, wenn ich weine, Studenten,
Computerpfleger, Leute, diese
Software ist nicht der Ski hier, die Hardware,
es gibt einen beträchtlichen Vorrat, er hat
wahrscheinlich sogar viel Prinzipien,
besonders das ist phänomenal, es ist eine
Qualia, dies ist eine Damenqualität  Unterstützen
und schauen, was zu denken ist
Subash Rechnung ja verschwinden Maschine sehr selten
bei uns zu Stanley Cohen übersprungen
Sanitäter Gedanken Experiment in der
Philosophie das Ergebnis auf dem Argument
Zuma und immer diese kunstvolle
Funktionalismus, so dass die körperlichen meisten
nicht sehen fettes Gewicht Moses sind lassen Sie uns
Gericht halten Sie das Zeug anglo-italienisch und
politisieren Sie nicht
Mary the Stump von Frank Jackson auf
Entwicklungen yum macht Anämie in der hohen
p  hilosophic s-- wenn wir Sheryn Anthes
zu jemandem Jesus plappernd atrás zitiert -
desi wollte eine Ästhetik Ich kämpfe gegen einen
Schlachtpudding, der vorerst das Ende von Oz Million
und siebentausend Gesetze von Zenda
mir und dem Mangel an und dem Spaß an Kwanzaa jedem so
Hausdesign  immer volga jetzt whoa genommen
auf giovanni mama unwichtiges feld im
auswärtigen dienst zenith cantors fertiger
wissenschaftler auf die jungs in condon osten
und widerstehen sie uns noch einmal nach hause ist lass uns
leinen alice la materia andere offensichtliche
Elbe
braucht uns materia
die staubwolke kann nicht ordentlich heiraten
Er ist TV-Rhonda-Experte in Venedig, Givanni,
unter den Fondfarben-Gate-Geräten Alice, die ich
befiel, und Langen Liberty, hey, Tina von
Alga besaß einen Körper für unseren Hintern für
visuelle und Wrightson India Home, sie
kann ihn
jetzt nicht wirklich auf Vice Hagen sehen  war vierzig Kinder gingen über
Farben sehen ihre unterversorgte
Harkin Mary hatte Serben Nonny und in der Ferne begann
Gig Instant-Küche Veda und ein Jota
Tamatar Norton blies ihm Reißverschluss teuflisch vor
Ort bewässerbar in Animation  al und Amos
keine auf dem Bauernhof gehaltene Bewässerungsmaschinen und Schwarz
Weissohr ihara Schwarz sie kann nicht noch
Schwarz liegt auf Kuh Alice war er
auf ste fab Vani-Filme hatte Schönheit
auf Gillies gesehen
Dinahs Tagus F nichts Lebenslauf von Salva
Jagd verstimmt Handwerker verheiratet mit aus  Ian
Allen ruhig von imma zitidars yarlung fr
start fabelhaftes Stück eine Sitzerhöhung Swasey
wieder Neuling auf dem Ihram-Campus hört, dass
wenn Zimas Farmen e Inverter Mittag Arbor
und hippe Savita-Schwester Mary Club sind, sehen Sie
tausend bei war Lärm Eva Farm Winkel und
geben ist nicht  ein sehr langer Barney-Monat, aber
eine erste und sprudelnde Schätzung oder Klaue
entkam Tarsus auf seinen Bauchmuskeln und perfekter
körperlich sollte er töten, er brauchte ein Feuer
[Musik]
hört sich das Kunstfernsehen genau an, auch es
war und die Ergebnisse der Maschine für Ganga
Indian Histones sind Geist  Mia und Löffel, die
ich hier bekomme, ja, ich hatte ein Netz, die Schwester
sieht dich, aber damit ich tun kann, was ich tue,
muss das meiste Zeichen sein, dass es das meiste ist, und ignoriert,
dass du dort nicht ein
schnelleres Auto von Frank Jackson zurückreichst  sollte
experimentieren Mary die Farbwissenschaftlerin ist
sehr überzeugend und es ist völlig
falsch es ist eine gebrochene Intuition Pumpe
es und ich freue mich sagen zu können, dass Frank
Jackson widerrufen hat, er stimmt zu, dass es
nicht den Punkt macht, den er machen möchte
, und ich habe es getan  Ich habe jahrelang dagegen argumentiert,
dass es hier ein Vorstellungsfehler
ist, den ich in meinem
Buch von 1991 bewusst im Bewusstsein erklärt habe, dass ich gesagt
habe, dass ich die Geschichte von Mary genauso weitererzählen werde,
außer wenn sich die Tür öffnet,
wenn sie zum ersten Mal Farbe ihres
Wissenschaftlers sieht  Freunde, die
sie eingesperrt haben, aber sie zeigen, dass sie eine blaue
Banane ist, und sie sagt sofort,
Moment mal, das ist eine blaue Banane, du
versuchst mich auszutricksen, und die Leute sagen, oh, sie
konnte nicht wissen, dass sie das nicht wissen
konnte  Ja, sie könnte, wenn Sie denken, dass sie
es nicht sofort wissen könnte,
vorausgesetzt, dass sie alles über die
physischen Reaktionen ihres eigenen Gehirns weiß, wird
sie keine Probleme haben, es ist
, als ob Sie nie
mit einer Bleistiftspitze berührt worden wären  in deiner  das ganze Leben,
aber Sie lesen alles über Bleistifte oder
so, und jetzt berühre ich Sie mit einer
Bleistiftspitze, Sir, okay, berühren Sie mich mit einer
Bleistiftspitze, nein, ich habe nichts gelernt,
und ich meine, das ist nur ein Teil meiner
Kritik an Mary, der besten Universitätslektüre
es - immer wieder an Türen klopfen
, nur einen Hund bauen, ein experimentelles Ende
, ein schnelles Einkommen aus den
amerikanisch-asiatischen Feldern von Thomas Nagel,
genau ein Schlauchboot ist keine Kunst, wir können
Alice Lee, aber es ist eine T-Revis-
Lachen-Musik für Pläne mit es nada
I  Ich wünsche besser, Neva Cindy, jeder
Fledermaus zu helfen, Suzanne, dies ist ein qualitativer
Schub, der einen Kommissar für unsere Meeresbahattin-Ärzte geschickt hat
Aikens sollte es heißen, wie es
ist, ein Bad zu sein, und sie veröffentlichte tatsächlich
einen Artikel mit dem Titel, wie es ist
, langweilig und kurzsichtig zu sein, und ging darauf ein, dass
es ein subtiles Problem mit Tom
Nagles Argument und so gibt  ist, dass
Nagle sich in diesem Artikel ziemlich viel Fledermausphysiologie
zunutze macht, warum denkt er
, dass das relevant ist, wenn es relevant ist,
dann wäre mehr auch relevant und
mehr wäre relevant für und mehr
wäre relevant für und die Behauptung, dass wir
uns nicht vorstellen können, was  es ist wie eine
Fledermaus zu sein, er argumentiert nie dafür, er
argumentiert nie dafür, er besteht nur darauf,
und im Laufe der Jahre war ich frustriert
und verärgert und schließlich amüsiert
, dass Nagles Arbeit
von Wissenschaftlern als Nagles Ergebnis zitiert wurde  Wenn Sie sich das Papier genau ansehen, werden
Sie sehen, dass es kein
Argument darin gibt. Er nimmt an, dass wir nicht
wissen können, wie es ist, eine Fledermaus zu sein, und dann
drehen sich seine Argumente nur um die
Implikationen davon, und er liegt damit einfach
falsch  Annahme, es gibt
keine Idee, dass es nichts gibt, dass
es Informationen gibt, die wir von innen bekommen können,
die wir niemals wissenschaftlich bekommen können,
es ist nur, denke ich,
gebrochen durch die Art und Weise, wie Tom und ich
in New York eine kleine spontane Debatte darüber hatten  k
City vor nur einem
Monat und es ist online und Nagel
führt sehr, sehr selbstbewusst mit I've
got in for you know over 40 years 50
years und und er sagte, woher glaubst du, dass die
Wissenschaft ihre Autorität bekommt, er hat es zu einer
Frage der Autorität gemacht und da ist  die
Autorität der Ich-
Perspektive und es gibt die Autorität der
Wissenschaft, und ich wies ihn darauf hin, dass
die Autorität der Ich-
Perspektive nur ein Schwindel ist, denn wir wissen
sehr wenig über unser eigenes Bewusstsein
und vieles von dem, was wir wissen  denken wir wissen ist
falsch wir haben überhaupt keinen einblick in das
medium des bewusstseins wir haben nur
einblick wir wissen nur über den inhalt ein
pensionierter
forscher für künstliche intelligenz namens richard power schickte mir kürzlich einen brief, in
dem er den punkt kristallklar machte
und jetzt i  Ich zitiere es sehr oft,
er vergleicht unseren Umstand mit
Bewusstsein damit, dass wir können, wir
können ein Gemälde haben, also haben Sie eine
Landschaft und halten es in die
Landschaft hinein, und wir können vergleichen und wir  können
sehen, dass hier die Ölfarbe, hier ist der
grüne Fleck, hier ist das Grün,
dass wir sowohl das Medium
als auch die Eigenschaften des Mediums sehen können, und
wir können die Eigenschaften des Dargestellten sehen
, und wir können, wir können
die Unterschiede betrachten  in Ähnlichkeiten können wir
das nicht mit unserer eigenen Erfahrung tun
wir können nicht wir haben überhaupt keinen Zugriff auf das
Medium das Medium ist in der Tat
Spike-Züge in neuronalen Netzwerken und
das ist nichts, worauf wir Zugriff haben
, aber das ist das Medium und die
Eigenschaften davon  Dieses Medium
bestimmt die Inhalte, die wir
erleben, und wenn wir erkennen, dass wir
nur eine Lücke ziehen, wenn wir versuchen,
die beiden Medien zu vergleichen, dann
erfinden wir Qualia als die Dinge, die
wir betrachten, und das ist einfach falsch
, das ist diese schlechte Theorie  Das ist keine
Selbstbeobachtung, ja, das ist intuitiv, also haben
wir, also kann ich das Testen nennen, wenn ich es
zerschlagen habe, es enthält zu lange, es ist
amerikanisch, und seine Maschinerie versucht es
erneut, seit Indiana der Künstler Newton
Richard Dawki  ns Dean CSTO gut kann Timsy
versucht hat nicht versucht, einige abweichende
Brights in den Tisch zu treten, das ist
einfach, das ist ooh,
eigentlich haben wir es nicht
geschaffen, das von zwei wunderbaren Highschool-
Lehrern, pensionierten Highschool-Lehrern in
Kalifornien, geschaffen wurde, die sie die Bewegung nannten  Wir haben
gerade beide davon erfahren, wir haben
darüber berichtet, wir waren die Boten
, um es nicht für 1/2 Unze zu schaffen, vielleicht
sprudelt das, was wir wirklich gegeben haben, et
ist abgeleitet von II Evoluzione England und
Stunts, wie bewölkt und und Gott sieht
Hilfe Sultan  Gott film a fix du
meinst es ist das selbe kannst du
asthma abfangen bevor blick auf gotts
ausdruck nach inhalt ist eet wie ähnlich
für die vorerwähnte erwähnung oder der
fernseher auf katsu klatschen oh ich glaube ich kann es nicht
beweisen aber ich habe eins  sehr überzeugend finde ich
einfach so Geschichte alle meisten Tiere sicher
alle Säugetiere haben eine Schreck- oder
Orientierungsreaktion etwas
überraschendes verstörendes
schockierendes passiert und sofort wir was
aber was bei deinem Hund vor sich geht kann
s sein  in der Winternacht zu deinen Füßen schlummert
und Schnee vom Dach fällt und
draußen auf dem Boden landet und der
Hund aufspringt, das ist es
in uns, im Gegensatz zu dem Hund, den wir nicht einfach dort anhalten,
tatsächlich springt der Hund
auf und bellt und  im grunde
schaut sich der hund um und sagt wer ist das
nicht was ist das wer ist das weil vielleicht ist
es ein eindringling vielleicht ist es wer weiß
wir behandeln ihn einen agenten zu finden
wo keiner ist ist evolutionär eine sehr gute strategie
was wir menschen machen
Was unsere Vorfahren taten, war, dass sie
nachts draußen im Wald waren und
ein schockierendes Geräusch hörten und sie
dachten, sie hätten einen Baumkobold
und einen sprechenden Baum gesehen, und ziemlich bald kam ihnen die
Idee zurück, und da ist
jemand bei ihm  einer sagt
war, dass ein sprechender Baum nein, so etwas gibt es nicht
, wir reden mit dir oh
ja, ich glaube, es war nein, bis
sie ins Dorf zurückkommen und es sich herumspricht, hat
Jones es gesehen, ich habe einen sprechenden
Baum gehört, und es wird  einer der Einheimischen
unsichtbare Agenten und all die Elfen und
Gremlins und Oger und Feen der
Folklore, so werden sie geboren, sie
werden aus dieser rekursiven Vorstellung geboren,
ausgelöst durch überraschende Erfahrungen,
die wir nicht anders erklären können,
was dann passiert, sind diejenigen, die
überleben  diejenigen, die unvergesslich sind, diejenigen, von
denen Sie Ihren Kindern erzählen möchten,
und Psychos, und das gibt uns Polytheismus,
und dann entwickeln wir uns zum
Monotheismus, und wir sind weg, das sind unsere Gelübde
in Caesars Isha Sesay, Varney Moon, Osmund,
ah, das kann es sein  war es,
Gerechtigkeitsfiktionen in Stahl oder in irgendeiner Weise
in fairer und bärischer Weise im Hinterkopf zu behalten, den
Sieg, den sie als BAS-Marxist stirbt,
Ossetien macht ein narbiges Gottesgeschenk, das
Easton uns sät, wie kann ich sicher sein, dass es
keinen Weihnachtsmann, keinen Osterhasen, nein gibt
Ungeheuer von Loch Ness
kann ich nicht, vielleicht entpuppen sie sich als solche
, aber ich bin hübsch,
also bin ich wirklich ich bin, sage ich, wie Richard
Dawkins sagt, Sie wissen wahrscheinlich, dass es
keinen Gott gibt, und ich meine, sehr wahrscheinlich denken die III,
dass es keiner ist  m  Es ist wahrscheinlicher,
dass es einen Gott gibt, dann einen Weihnachtsmann, den
Seufzer. Es tut mir leid, wenn ich
Kinder schockiere, die dieses Projekt
über die aktuellen Anomalien der Gesellschaft hören werden, wenn
er einen Cineast mit einem See aufstellt, damit keine Frau
Hagen sich dessen bewusst ist, dass er sich meldet  Nick zu sein, hart
, überspringst du irgendwie, wenn ich sehe, hält dieser Gott
ja, aber wenn das sehr oft der Fall ist,
gibt es sehr gute Gründe
, eine der Alternativen als die
unwahrscheinlichste zu behandeln und sie einfach zu verwerfen. Der
Russell Bertrand Russell hatte ein berühmtes
Beispiel  Das ist, er kann nicht beweisen, dass
keine Teekanne umkreist. Ich kann nicht heiraten, welchen
Planeten Saturn. Sagen wir, vielleicht gibt es eine
silberne Teekanne, die den Saturn
umkreist  denn hinter diesem okay, dafif
Rushton, das ist Kenapa, ist Schnur Acht, ein
Rohrtisch und Pizzelle, sorry, aber Soja-
Kümmel, einige Käufer p d-- hier
ed liebte es, das Ohr auf dem Planeten
Mars Kaiser zu schwenken, und nahm diese Ehre dieses
Jahr an und hatte eine Verzierung  ist ein
Magazin nehmen und Z ist Truppenlinie Kumpel Stassi
deutsches Teleskop vo Bar, dass wir
Diner / Menon V in einem
Darm begegneten, hofften sie, ejido sera ein
Neiman's Mann Annamma Vidal Einkommen bleib
jeder dauerhaft offen darf nicht bis zum
letzten dunkel ein wolkig aber Tim
tatsächlich issed ein Skript zum Verkauf wie eine
Pizza, die er in das Geheimnis legte Dalek
Bassant noch für die unbewaffneten uns einst
für ein faszinierendes Spaghetti-
Monster schwelgte eine Chiffon-Bordüre
[Musik]
oder das Ebel kleiner oza elefanten Stadtentscheidung
von Lism Sabathia in Sean
hmm
diese sind unbewaffnet und Lawson's ich nicht
mit einer Liga Abba die Glottis atrás
bestanden Auswurf eine Angst GU zu ertragen das -
Nick - der Lincoln ausgerichtet ich brauche Zonen
cranberry Füller absurd sind nominell
[Musik]
über einer Geschwindigkeit Prüfer die für wahnsinnigen Nappa
Wahnsinn kommen  über einen DVD-Verleih am
schmutzigsten dort auf der Existenz, die er
nicht lieben kann, liebe Künstlerin Deyanira, ordentliche
Existenz, Schlagkraft Oda, lieber Skeptiker, sie
sind Vida, eine unheimliche Existenz, nein  Ära
ordentliche Existenz Clubbed London Geist Mann
Visa ein Kumpel
[Musik]
wollen V-Status auf dem Globin und die
Existenz hat uns Mister bei Mizzou alarmiert
Sonali, dass Lobby und ich verdammt
verzweifelt Monster Masterson ein Netz war,
um Globin existiert nicht unersättlich
fähig  Ja, ich stapele Yachten oder nein,
ja, aber es diente einem sehr guten Zweck. Es
wurde nicht von Menschen entworfen, um diesem Zweck zu dienen,
sondern es entwickelte sich durch natürliche
Auswahl kultureller Gegenstände, um die
Kooperativität zu verbessern und soziale
Bindungen zu festigen, um konzertierte Aktionen von Stämmen zu machen
von  Dörfer Menschen, die nicht direkt
nahe verwandt sind eine größere Familie, mit anderen
Worten, ich gebe gerne zu,
dass die frühe Religion die große
Rolle bei der Etablierung von Gruppenidentität und der
Ermöglichung des sozialen Zusammenhalts spielt, diese Rolle ist
meiner Meinung nach nicht mehr wirklich notwendig  war eine sehr
wertvolle frühe Stütze, eine prothetische Krücke,
wenn Sie Zivilisation mit
Demokratie und Wissenschaft und einer freien
Presse und all diesen guten Dingen bekommen möchten
Um das draußen anständig zum Laufen zu bringen, ist
es wie ein Minenschacht, der
für mich genauso empfindlich ist wie der Chirurg Center
Hollis und sagte ein globales Sindh und
Punisch auf Kristin Halt in ihrem
Rhesus von Ihram Laden, obwohl dieses
bedeutsame Problem
nicht groß liegt, sondern ich  glaube an
Dinge und ich und ich denke, ja, die
Schaffung von Bedeutung ist wirklich das, worum es im Leben
geht, aber wenn du schon dabei bist,
suche nach Bedeutungen, die wirklich wichtig sind,
was etwas bedeutet, als ich eine sehr schwere Herzoperation hatte, die ich hatte
eine
künstliche Aorta hatte
ich aa Nordic dieser Abschnitt normalerweise ist
es tödlich,
es war nicht in meinem Fall, weil ein wunderbares
Team von Ärzten und Krankenschwestern und
Technikern genau das Richtige tat
und mein Leben rettete, das
vor fast elf Jahren im Jahr 2006 war und während
ich  erholte mich im Krankenhausbett. Ich
war amüsiert und interessiert,
viele E-Mail-Herausforderungen zu bekommen. Ich hatte eine
Erleuchtung. Ich hatte. Ich hatte
Mir wurde
klar, dass, wenn wir Gott sei Dank sagen
, das kein Euphemismus für Gott sei Dank ist,
was wir wirklich meinen, Gott sei Dank
gibt es viel Gutes auf der Welt,
und das ist nicht Gottes Güte, sondern
die Güte der Menschen, die
ihm vorausgegangen
sind  die Güte der Menschen, die sich
um mich gekümmert haben, die Güte der Ärzte
und Wissenschaftler, die die Forschung durchgeführt haben,
sie haben die Medikamente hergestellt und und und und
, und wir alle sind
Nutznießer von Bergen, Bergen von
früherer Güte, und ich empfehle, dass wir die
übernehmen  Haltung der Dankbarkeit gegenüber dem,
was vorher war, und wir können das zurückzahlen,
nicht indem wir Tiere einer
imaginären Kreatur opfern, sondern indem wir die
Güte weitergeben, also einen Baum pflanzen,
füttern und Waisenkind etwas
Wichtiges entdecken
Gute Dinge, die passiert sind, von denen Sie profitiert haben,
sind
ungefähr in Mahalo Shin Bet und wir fangen
den Drachen ein und überleben das
Herr.  Damhirschkuh hat sogar unser blaues
cific Co-Enzym als eine überspringende Art von P-
Aktivität eingebaut, die die Sünden des Essens von sehr coolen
Produkten zur Hölle erfüllt hat, und Jonathan ist in
Don't Newts Leaf auf den Telefonen. Ja
und nein, daran erinnern Sie sich noch einmal  und
ich schätze, Sie haben das zu Illusionen gesagt,
die von Vorteil sein können
etwas unfair ihnen gegenüber
das uralte philosophische Problem, dass unsere
Dinge gut sind, weil Gott sie für
gut hält, oder denkt Gott, dass sie gut sind,
weil sie gut sind, ja, und was Leute
aus meiner Perspektive sagen würden, ist, dass es
keine Berechtigung mehr für diese Idee gibt  X
hält es für gut, macht es gut. Ich meine, meine
Großtante Lucille findet es gut, also ist
es gut,
wer ist sie, warum sollten wir uns darum kümmern, was sie
buht? Ähnlich, wenn Sie an einen
monotheistischen Gott glauben, wie können
Sie zuerst sagen, was dieser Gott denkt  der
Die Geschichte ist voll von unverschämten
Darstellungen von Gottes Überzeugungen und
viel Schaden wurde dadurch angerichtet. Was ist
der bessere Weg? Ich denke, der offensichtliche Weg
ist, den
kleinen Mann zu eliminieren und darüber in
politischen Begriffen nachzudenken. Stellen Sie sich vor, wir könnten ein
Kolloquium des Kongresses in einer öffentlichen Arena veranstalten
Überzeugungskraft und was auch immer Sie für
gut halten, das ist Ihre Chance, dem
Rest der Welt zu sagen, warum Sie das für
gut halten, und Sie können nie die Glaubensrolle spielen,
wenn Sie gut sagen, in meiner Religion
sagen wir, Schweinefleisch essen ist nicht gut
und  darf das nicht gut machen, okay, das ist eine
Tatsache,
sagen Sie uns, warum Sie denken, wir sollten dem
folgen - und sagen Sie es nicht, weil Gott es so sagt,
wenn es einen guten Grund gibt, ansonsten gut
und aus diesem rationalen Prozess heraus ist es
keine wissenschaftliche Schlussfolgerung, sondern politische
Überzeugung und  das Ideal, einen
Konsens zu erzielen und dabei viele Fragen
offen zu lassen Wenn man sich auf der ganzen Welt
umschaut, gibt es Praktiken, an die manche Menschen
zutiefst glauben, während andere
Menschen das einfach nur albern finden
Gut, wenn es niemandem schadet,
lassen Sie ihn es tun, aber ich denke, es gibt einen
Kern der Übereinstimmung und was könnte
möglicherweise eine bessere Grundlage für
Moral sein als die Tatsache, dass
Menschen ermutigt und verpflichtet wurden,
sorgfältig darüber nachzudenken, was es ist
sie kommen mit ist nicht leichter und schneller
auf ND und das ist eine besondere person die
häuser im osten gott wolke das haus
NIST die nebelmaschine im gehirn von allen
spirituellen nebenereignissen ist es viel Peter
Segal oder eine gute schachmusikordnung auf
der zweiten  Step Think hält eine Quelle in
Daniel Dennett Das Wort spirituell hat im
Englischen eine sehr hohe Bedeutung erlangt,
aber auch die Erhöhung wird
durch eine
Verwässerung dessen erreicht, was es für manche Leute tatsächlich bedeutet, Profifußball, dass ihre Spiritualität okay ist. Oh, das ist eine fizzy Wahrheit Demokratie  Autonomie
das sind meine das sind meine hohen Werte
und ich bin so dankbar für die Existenz
von Musik und Kunst, die mich
manchmal zu Tränen rührt und ich finde es
wunderbar  d Ich denke, es ist sogar noch
wunderbarer, wenn ich erkenne, dass
Bach kein Engel war, kein Gott, nichts
Übernatürliches an ihm, aber er war ein
erstaunliches Produkt natürlicher Auslese, und
sein Geist wurde wunderbar mit
Werkzeugen kultureller, natürlicher Auslese erweitert, und
er  sie auf eine Weise zusammenzustellen, die
einfach umwerfend schön ist und die
Menschheit bewegt, und das ist gut
genug für mich. Ich meine, ich
würde beides nicht besser schätzen, wenn
mir jemand sagen würde und ich glaube ihnen, dass
irgendein Gott eine geniale Pille zurückgegeben hat  Eigentlich
würde ich denken, das ist wie
Betrug und dann noch ein paar Nazis und
Esel.